we are on problem number six problem
number six if there is no waste how many
square yards of carpeting is needed to
cover a rectangular floor that is 12
feet by 18 feet so it's I can just draw
it like that and it's 12 feet by 18 feet
and the trick here is they're not asking
how many feet they're asking how many
square yards of carpeting so the easiest
thing to do really at this point is to
convert the dimensions of the of the of
the room two yards they tell us a three
feet make a yard so 18 yards 18 feet
that's the same thing as 1/3 and you get
that's six yards six yards is 18 feet
and what you divide by three you get
four yards i always find them the
arithmetic the hardest part 4 yards is
equal to 12 feet right 4 times 3 is
equal to 12 so now this is a six by four
so six yards times four yards is equal
to 24 square yards and that's choice C
and the mistake if you got this wrong
you might have just well one you might
have multiplied 12 x 18 and gotten a
very large number and then say they'll
that's the answer but then your answer
would've been in defeat whether the
other mistake you might have done is you
might have multiplied 12 x 18 you might
have done this 12 x 18 divided by 3
because you said oh 3 feet is equal yard
and that is a mistake because you're now
converting square feet to square yards
and it's actually there's three there's
actually you should have divided by nine
because there's actually nine square
feet per square yard why is that because
if I had let's say this is a one square
yard right that means it's going to be
three feet on that side three feet on
that side so it's actually nine square
feet so if you figured out the area in
feet for first you have to divide by 9
not by three that probably was that's
probably the most common mistake
assuming that you realize that you have
to convert units next problem problem 7
a certain scale only registers weights
that are greater than six pounds okay
fair enough a person who wanted to know
the weights of a puppy a kitten and a
bunny very cute Wade them in pairs and
got the following results kitten plus
bunny weighed seven pounds so kitten
plus bunny is seven kitten plus puppy is
eight kitten plus puppy is equal to
eight and bunny plus puppy is nine bunny
plus puppy is equal to nine very this is
by far the cutest problem I've ever done
what is the weight of the puppy so we
want to solve for P well if we're going
to solve for P that the best thing we
could do is we want to use these two
equations but we have three if we just
look at these two equations we have
three unknowns with two equations so
let's use this equation to substitute
into this equation so let's say we want
to replace this K so we could use this
top equation to say that k is equal to
seven minus B right so if we substitute
that into this equation will get so let
me just this is 7-3 so we'll get seven
minus B and I'm just rewriting this top
equation that's this plus P is equal to
eight and then this bottom equation
still is that this bottom equation still
is B plus P is equal to nine I could add
the seven or subtract seven from both
sides right now but I'm just going to
actually add the equations because I
like on these beats going to cancel i
get excited about cancelling variables
so actually no let me add let me
subtract seven from both sides first so
if we take seven from here then this
eight becomes a 1 right I just
subtracted 7 from both sides so negative
b plus p is equal to one now i just add
these two equations so what's minus b
plus B it's 0 plus P plus P is too p is
equal to one plus 9 is 10 too p equals
10 p is equal to 5 choice d 5 pounds
that's how much the puppy ways
which shows us the bunny weighs two
pounds and the kitten weighs three
pounds which is it looks like they
actually thought about how much a puppy
a bunny in a kitten would actually way
which which I have to give them credit
for next problem problem eight on a
blueprint one-fourth inch one-fourth
inch represents 16 feet in real life if
a driveway is 40 feet long what is its
length in inches on the map so a
driveway let me just that's a driveway I
don't know I guess you know that's my
driveway and it's 40 feet long 40 feet
long so how many of these units is it
going to be how many units is it going
to be well actually right well we could
do it a bunch of different ways we could
say one fourth of an inch is equal to 16
feet if we multiply both sides in this
relationship by four you get one inch is
equal to 64 feet right one inch i just
multiply both sides of this relationship
by four so if you want to figure out how
many inches this would represent you
would say well X is how many inches it
would represent over one inch is equal
to this length 40 feet over 64 right
it's the same fraction and of course if
you divide by 1 this this cancels out
right so you're left with X which is its
representation in inches is equal to 40
/ 64 whether you can divide the top and
the bottom by eight so that becomes five
over eight right 40 / 5 64 divided by 8
x is equal to five eighths and that is
choice B next problem there's a bunch of
ways you could have done this way that I
don't know occurred to me next problem
problem 9
in the XY coordinate system p comma 0 is
one of the points of intersection of the
graphs okay so they're giving us two
graphs y is equal to minus x squared
plus 9 and the other graph is y is equal
to x squared minus 9 if p is positive p
is positive positive what is the value
of P so they're saying that the
coordinate where they intersect is P
comma 0 right so we want to figure out
the x-coordinate where they where they
intersect so the easy way you know
they're attempting you to add these
equations and do all sorts of things but
we know that they intersect at the point
y is equal to 0 they're telling us that
so we don't have to do all this fancy
stuff we'd have to figure out where they
intersect they tell us intersects at y
equals 0 so y equals 0 what's X in
either of these situations well let's
take the second equation 0 is equal to x
squared minus 9 and 9 to both sides yet
x squared is equal to 9 I added 9 and
switch the sides and you get x is equal
to plus or minus 3 and if you look at
these tell us that if P is positive what
is the value of P well has to be plus 3
then and that is choice a and you can
use the top equation you could have said
0 is equal to negative x squared plus 9
you have gotten the same thing you've
got an x squared is equal to 9 x is
equal to plus or minus 3 you've gotten
the same thing either way next problem I
don't know if I'm enough time to do it
in this video I might have to do it in
the next problem 10
the Smith metal company's old machine
makes 300 volts per hour 300 I'll call
it B / h its new machine makes 450 volts
per hour 450 volts per hour if both
machines begin running at the same time
how many minutes will it take the two
machines to make a total of nine hundred
volts so how many minutes so let's say m
four minutes so the total number of
bolts are going to produce so bolts
bolts bolts sorry bolts is going to be
equal so this is per hour right these
are both per hour so let's figure it out
let's figure it out minutes because
they're asking us how many minutes will
it take so if you make 300 bolts in an
hour you're going to make 160th that in
a minute so what's one sixtieth of 300
well 300 divided by 60 is five bolts per
minute and this one what's 450 / 64
50/60 actually I'm going around a time
I'm going to do this problem in the next
video see you soon